(mellow electronic music)
- I was called names such as monster,
two-face and scar face.
Hey guys, welcome back to my channel.
Posting my videos made me realize
that this is my mission.
I wouldn't take it back.
This is absolutely the
reason why it happened to me.
Hey guys, welcome back to my channel.
If you're new, my name is Shalom Blac.
Today, we are going to be doing makeup.
My name is Shalom, and
I make YouTube videos.
I teach people how to do makeup
and also encourage them to love themselves
for who they are without the makeup.
I was burned by cooking oil
when I was nine years old
in my mother's restaurant back in Nigeria.
I remember waking up just screaming
and pulling off my skin
and rubbing off my face.
It was really terrible for me.
I thought of suicide.
I was in the mirror
just looking at myself,
like, why don't people just like me?
And I know that my mom loved me
and she would be really, um, sad
to lose a child, you know,
because she felt like
she already lost one.
I'm sorry.
This is real pretty.
I started to feel better about myself
when I saw other people
that were burned, too,
and I wanted to help people like me.
My solution was trying to cover up my scar
so I thought why not makeup?
This is gonna be a
talk-through, step-by-step,
how I cover up the scar on my face.
When I get comments from my viewers
telling me that I help them,
it makes me remember why I'm doing this.
I like to focus positivity
on my videos, you know,
not just putting on the makeup,
but having a message that comes with it,
that makeup isn't just what
I love to do, you know.
I wanna make you feel good
even when you don't have the make up on.
I'm just happy because I found myself.
I learned to accept my scars,
and I also just love me for who I am.